>> Jesse: TENSIONS FLARING
BETWEEN NANCY PELOSI AND
LAWMAKERS, SUCH AS ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
SHE VOTED AGAINST LAST MONTH
BORDER AND THE SPEAKER DOES --
THIS WITH DEMOCRAT AND OTHER
FRESHMAN DEMOCRATS TOWING
"NEW YORK TIMES" COME ALL THESE
PEOPLE HAVE THEIR PUBLIC
WHATEVER AND THEIR TWITTER
WORLD.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
FOLLOWINGS.
THERE ARE FOUR PEOPLE AND THAT'S
HOW MANY BOATS A GOD.
IF THE LEFT DOESN'T THINK I'M
LEFT ENOUGH, SO BE IT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A SOLUTION, NOT
JUST A TWITTER FIGHT.
AOC IS FIRING BACK TWEETING "I
FIND IT STRANGE THAT MEMBERS ACT
AS THOUGH SOCIAL MEDIA IS NOT
IMPORTANT.
THEY SET MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
FIRE TO RUN TV ADS SO PEOPLE CAN
SEE THEIR MESSAGE.
I HAVEN'T DIALED FOR DOLLARS
ONCE THIS YEAR AND HAVE MORE
TIME TO DO MY ACTUAL JOB.
YET WE WOULD RATHER CAMPAIGN
LIKE IT'S 2008."
WHAT DO YOU SAY, DANA?
>> Dana: LOOK, I ADMIRE HER
FIGHT, RIGHT IN SPITE SHE BRINGS
TO IT.
>> Juan: YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
AOC.
>> Dana: I ALSO ADMIRED
NANCY PELOSI BECAUSE SHE CAN
COUNT VOTES.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT ELECTED IN
YOUR DISTRICT, YES, IT IS EASIER
TO BE FIREBRAND AND DO ALL OF
THOSE THINGS.
SPEAK OF PELOSI A DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITY AND A DIFFERENT
ROLE.
HER JOB IS TO KEEP THE MAJORITY
AND FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO AS
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO WITH THE
REALITY THAT THEY LIVE IN.
AND IF THEY CONTINUE TO GO THE
WAY THAT THEY ARE, THOSE 31
DISTRICTS, AND THE HOUSE THAT
HELPED NANCY PELOSI BECOME
SPEAKER AGAIN COULD VERY
EASILY SLIP BACK TO A REPUBLICAN
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP IS AT THE
TOP OF THE TICKET.
THE REPUBLICANS BECAUSE NOT AS
MANY PEOPLE VOTE MIDTERM.
THE OTHER THING, SHE DID AN
INTERVIEW, SPEAKER PELOSI DID
WITH "THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
GOT A LOT OF ATTENTION WHERE SHE
IS SAYING THESE GUYS DON'T ONLY
HAVE A TWITTER GAME.
IT CAME OUT OF AN INTERESTING
TIME.
BECAUSE SHE JUST LOST A FIGHT
WITH ENTEROCOCCUS BUT NOT FROM
THE LEFT.
IT WAS FROM THE MIDDLE.
THEY SAID, WE HAVE TO VOTE FOR
THE FUNDING FOR THE BORDER.
AND SO COME I THINK SHE IS
TRYING TO BE WISE.
I THINK THAT I UNDERSTAND A PUSH
UP AGAINST HER, BUT IF I HAD TO
PUT PELOSI'S POLITICAL SKILLS UP
AGAINST AOC AT THIS MOMENT FROM
WHAT THEY NEED, IF I WERE THE
DEMOCRATS, CAN'T YOU GUYS WORK
TOGETHER?
THEY CAN BE QUITE POWERFUL BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF IT IS POSSIBLE.
>> Juan: I JUST DON'T THINK
THERE IS ANY WAY CONGRESSMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IS ON
THE SAME POWER GAME LEVEL AS
NANCY PELOSI.
AND THEY ARE BOTH CLEARLY
SHOWING THAT, BUT GREG, WHAT WAS
INTERESTING TO ME, THERE WAS A
NOTE OF CONTENT.
IN THE WAY THAT PELOSI SPOKE
ABOUT THE MEDIA AND TWITTER.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> Juan: AND THEN YOU SEE THIS
PUNCH BACK FROM AOC, YOU ARE
LIVING IN 2,009?
>> Greg: I ENJOYED THIS FIGHT.
IT IS SO MUCH FUN.
THE REPUBLICANS EXPERIENCED
THREE, FOUR YEARS AGO BUT TRUMP
RATTLED THE PARTY AND HE RATTLED
THE PARTY USING SIMILAR TOOLS
WHICH WAS SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE ALL THOUGHT THIS IS NOT EASY,
WE THOUGHT IT WAS CRAZY,
LAUGHING, ENJOYING AND HE BEAT
EVERYBODY WITH IT.
YOU KNOW?
AOC HAS A CHIP OFF THE OLD
TRUMP.
I THINK SHE KNOWS HOW TO WORK
IT.
AND I THINK THAT THEY COULD
PROBABLY LEARN FROM THAT.
IT DOES BOTHER ME THAT SHE
DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE BILL.
I MEAN, THAT IS KIND OF STRANGE
WHEN YOU ACCUSE OTHERS OF
HURTING MIGRANT CHILDREN AND
THEN DENY THEIR AID.
THAT SEEMS TO SUGGEST MAYBE THIS
IS A POLITICAL, CYNICAL ACT OF
THE EIGHT OR ON HER PART WHEN
MAYBE LET PEOPLE SUFFER AND DIE
BEFORE COOPERATING WITH THE
PRESIDENT?
THAT IS SAD.
>> Juan: WHAT I'M REMINDED OF
IS JOHN BOEHNER, PAUL RYAN, I
THINK PAUL RYAN IS TO THE LEFT,
THE CAUCUS.
AND HERE IS ONE DEALING WITH THE
SAME DYNAMICS TO THE FAR RIGHT
BUT IT IS THE FAR LEFT.
>> Jesse: I THINK WEINER HAS
TO HAVE -- YOU THINK YOU HAVE IT
BAD TO.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK IT IS
WINE ANYMORE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: SHE HAS FOUR BOMB
THROWERS AND HE HAS DOZENS OF
TEA PARTY MEMBERS STARTING IN
2,010.
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS THAT MADE
HIS LIFE HELL OVER SPENDING AND
THE DEBT CEILING.
HE DID HIS BEST TO KEEP THE BEEF
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
NANCY SEEMS TO KEEP HAVING THESE
PUBLIC SPATS.
SHE'S ONLY GOT FOUR LITTLE BOMB
THROWERS.
AND IT'S -- SHE'S HAD FIGHTS
ABOUT ANTI-SEMITISM,
IMPEACHMENT, PROGRESSIVISM AND
THE BORDER FUNDING THING.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
AND SHE WOULD JUST BE MUCH
BETTER SERVED IF SHE WOULD LET
HER TEAM HANDLE THE DRAMA AND
IGNORE THEM.
NOW, SHE HAS NICKED NAMED THEM
THE SQUAD, ELEVATING THEM IN THE
MEDIA.
AND THIS IS WRONG BUT I DO AGREE
WITH AOC.
YOU SHOULDN'T DIMINISH THE POWER
OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
SHE DOESN'T DIAL COLOR FOR
DOLLARS AND SHE KIM LEVEL THAT
PLATFORM.
AND I THINK SHE SHOULD SOON.
>> Juan: KATIE, WHAT IS
INTERESTING TO ME, PEOPLE ON THE
RIGHT ARE HOPING THAT THERE IS A
BIG RIFT IN A BIG FIGHT COMING,
RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW IF AT ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS AT THE LEVEL
THAT SHE CAN TAKE ON
NANCY PELOSI.
>> Katie: THEY ARE NOT HOPING
FOR IT BUT IT'S ALREADY HERE AND
WE ARE WATCHING IT PLAY OUT.
THAT IS THE REASON YOU HAVE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS IN EVERY
INTERVIEW ABOUT THIS NEW CAUCUS
PEOPLE THAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING IS
NOT POWERFUL.
SHE IS BEING ASKED ABOUT IT,
COMMENT ON IT IN EVERY
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE WE
WHETHER THEY BELIEVE IN THE
GREEN NEW DEAL AND MEDICARE FOR
OLD.
GUESS WHO'S DRIVING THAT
NARRATIVE THESE FOUR PEOPLE AND
I WITH US -- THAT THEY WISH THEY
COULD GO ON THE COVER OF
ROLLING STONE WHEN NANCY PELOSI
WAS ON WITH ILHAN OMAR AND
COOPERATION THEN, BUT THIS IS
TOO PACKED.
NANCY PELOSI IS DOING WHAT DANA
TALKED ABOUT.
LOOKING TO GOVERN.
LOOKING FOR POLICIES AND RESULTS
TO GO BACK TO THE DISTRICT TO
SAY, NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
THINGS PASSING LEGISLATION THAT
WILL PASS THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
BUT AOC AND ILHAN OMAR AND
PROCEEDED TO LEAP INTERESTED IN
THE CULTURAL BATTLE OVERALL.
THEY ARE ACTIVIST AND DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT GETTING REELECTED
IN THEIR DISTRICT BUT WANT TO
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE WITH THE
WHOLE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE DOING THAT.
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT THEM,
THE MEDIA TAKEN UP BY THEM LAST
WEEK AND AOC OF ACCUSED BORDER
PATROL OF FORCING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT -- ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
TO DRINK OUT OF TOILET BOWLS.
SO THEY ARE TOO PASSIVE AND
DIFFERENT AT THIS POINT, WHETHER
NANCY PELOSI IS VICTORIOUS RIGHT
NOW.
>> Greg: THE MEDIA DID A GREAT
JOB FOLLOWING UP ON THAT
ACCUSATION.
WE REALLY GOT TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE TOILET DRINKING.
>> Juan: BY THE WAY, CLEARLY
THE SPRINT OF THE CAUCUS AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY WENT WITH
PELOSI -- WITH PELOSI.
>> Katie: WITH -- >> Juan:
HOW TO VOTE IN CONGRESS.
>> Katie: YOU CAN DO BOTH AT
THE SAME TIME.
DEAL WITH THE OVERALL NARRATIVE
AND DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY AND
THEN YOU CAN DEAL WITH THE